hey guys it is Friday which means I've
got five of this week's best gaming
related stories all ready to go for you
here's what matters Peter Mullan you had
a really crappy week this week and if
you missed it here the cringy cliff
notes his company 22 can seems to be
having trouble with a number of staff
leaving both involuntarily and those who
decided to move away from goddess to
other products then it became apparent
that 22 kids is unlikely to be able to
fulfill its goddess Kickstarter promises
such as producing a Linux version and
implementing multiplayer if all that
wasn't bad enough the winner of his last
game curiosity who were supposed to get
this grand prize in goddess and a cut of
its profits has said he's received
nothing from the company in the near two
years since he chopped out that tiny
laughs digital cube super not cool super
awkward Molyneux said he's working to
rectify it
titanfall 2 is in the news again this
week and it's being strongly suggested
that the next entry may not be Xbox
exclusive on consoles although still
officially unannounced EA CFO Blake
Jorgensen has said quote we'll probably
have another titanfall game it will
probably be a bigger footprint than just
a single platform I think that's a huge
positive for us yogen son also said he
her PA will deliver at least one UF yes
every year with battlefield hardline and
star wars battlefront this year
battlefield 5 or whatever it'll be
called next year and perhaps titanfall 2
in 2017 and now it's a little bit of my
show which means free stuff time and
your allocated free stuff for this week
is ps4 online multiplayer for the
weekend Sonia having themselves a free
weekend for anybody with a ps4 who is
keen on checking out the multiplayer
bits in their games that doesn't have a
PS Plus subscription you'll be able to
play online as much as you want from
februari 1337 16 because who the hell
needs valentine's day when you can kill
off your friends on the internet
its water that is an individual who
trolls emergency services and colvin
fake incidents to swat teams could be
facing up to five years in prison the
superbly crappy act of terrifying
someone by calling armed emergency
personnel on them has landed 19 year old
Brandon Wilson with a rated home on
suspicion of multiple squatting
incidents Wilson was coincidentally
arrested at the same time that a live
stream of fell victim to a squatting
hearts we're in his younger brothers had
guns pulled on them summary time
swatting needs to stop it's expensive
cruel dangerous and illegal finally
today Ian said they reckon tablets could
be more powerful than console by 2018
personally I barely even game on my
phone but ea's Blake Jorgensen has said
what gets us the most excited is the
power the computing power of mobile
devices and the speed at which that's
growing what that might mean is that a
tablet of three or four years from now
has more power than what a typical
console has and that will open up a
whole new set of people to console style
games that are much more immersive much
deeper much more character-driven than
simply a static mobile game that you
might play for a small bursts of time
while you're waiting for the bus let me
know down in the comments if you game on
your phone or tablet and if you reckon
those devices can surpass consoles this
week on site check out my gist episode
on evolve featuring a guest host and
bloopers Lucy explains what's not so
compelling about Telltale's Game of
Thrones and Danny talks the crappiness
of DLC on the point that is everything
that I have been this week but be sure
to have yourself a lovely weekend
whether you'll be celebrating
valentine's day playing video games or
whatever else I'll catch you again on
Monday
you